number three photo in India the roads
are melting it's just too hard to
believe temperatures roast over 116
degrees Fahrenheit 45 degrees Celsius
the distinction is the percentage of
Indians without electricity which means
no AC no fans no nothing
well there's also they're also having
trouble getting access to water as well
it's a much worse situation there than
it would be here it's expected to last
them for at least two days the monsoon
is later this year that's the problem so
this is linked to the lack of a monsoon
this is linked to the lack of monsoon
May is always the hottest month it's
just been so much worse this year and
it's been worse for longer because you
know because they're just waiting for
the rains to come number two in San
Francisco
uber released renderings of its new
headquarters Tom I would argue that the
second you as a company release the
sketch of your new headquarters that's
when everybody should run for the door I
would argue that the third floor I paid
for you know nobody is more bullish on
uber than Tom we use it I mean it's it
just works it's incredible I think it's
over is a game-changer yes it has been
for me I mean the ability to pull up on
your mobile device yeah a car and it
comes you track it and it comes within
minutes and then to be tracked in the
car but but do this to your point there
go we got an uber headquarters of
Facebook categories it's an Apple
building some monstrous exactly app
Apple is building the mothership it's
under the California boomer tab yeah
yeah do you buy into the theory that the
second the company builds its ambitious
new headquarters that's when you should
be careful watching
maybe get everybody out of trouble right
now we're gonna go to Maryland to
spellers by the name of Vanya left and
go cool right celebrate after winning
the 2015 Scripps spelling bee they're
co-champs that is a tie for the second
year in a row that were not enough words
left for them to keep facing off Vanya
correctly spelled the word Sheeran
Schnitzer you could have done that I
could have done that but that's only
because German is my only party trick go
cool spelled nunataq I don't even know
what a nunataq is Sharon snippet of that
you make with scissors cutting paper I
don't know what a nunataq is Tom's
looking it up right now in the meantime
they took home a trophy and a 35
thousand dollar prize what is it nunataq
1877 a peak of braga mountains are lofty
on the sides of the fjords steep now we
know okay now we know